c'est une très longue réveil histoire je
désire c'est déjà première édition en 79
ou ben j'ai eu moi la chance d'y
participer
malheureusement en tant que arbitre
staff avec l'ancien président robert
richard
c'est des moments forts même je me
demande si on n'a même pas beaucoup plus
de pression que les joueurs en étant
assis sur le banc essayer de trouver les
bonnes solutions
au moment opportun pour les aider ça va
très bien hubert ça va rouler tu vas des
anciens les premiers jeux en 79
c'est là où ou le tennis de table à la
réunion a commencé à prendre une
évolution forte
ça veut dire on était à l'époque il y
avait que trois clubs à l'époque à la
réunion grands clubs phares du tampon
qui devait avoir au moins peut-être une
dizaine une vingtaine de licenciés à
peine d'accord les aiglons d'orient qui
avait peut-être le double trip à peu
près et château morange qui avait quatre
ou cinq joueurs mais on ne jouer les
compétitions se jouer sur des tables
loisy à toutes les grandes compétitions
après les jeux dont pendant les jeux on
a plus à voir si table ch'ti gars les
premiers à table homologué officiel de
compétition les marqueurs les
séparations et tout ce qui s'en suivent
c'était c'était le début et on est passé
juste après à plus de 100 licenciés plus
beaux moments et des moments difficiles
et un goût amer c'est
quand même 2007 parce que on pas à
madagascar
on l'attendait pas les filles c'est
qu'on est quand même arrivé en finale
simple personne ne s'y attendait alors
là je vous parle et j'ai encore les
fruits sont sur moi parce que et c'était
picard audrey un qui fait la finale
première fois je vois autant de monde à
la réunion dans un stade pour assister à
un match de ping et là je suis seul au
milieu avec pas loin de 5000 personnes
autour a coaché picard audrey qui
justement mène 2 set 0
le staff réunionnais qui est derrière
qui commencent à sortir le drapeau
français qui me montre moi je regarde
discrètement d ailleurs se roula et une
pression énorme
audrey picard est la peine 18 ans à ce
moment là et elle craque parce que en
face il ya doute une joueuse malgache
aller n'est pas parce que quand je vais
dans une salle de ping aujourd'hui la
plupart des joueurs les anciens
je touche deux joueurs que en partie à
un moment donné j'ai entraîné par daniel
et fg des photos daniel était gamin
avant de partir de la réunion ce sens
18 les jeunes aussi comme le monsieur
oui des jeunes comme canadair devaient
être présentés sont leur côté là bas que
ce soit au niveau staff ligue et où il
ya une baisse de tension qui fait que
pendant une période on est un peu on
s'endort
alors au lieu de rebondir directement
dessus et de trouver les moyens pour
attirer les jeunes comptent y fait dans
une continuité relancer systématiquement
les collectivités pour des aides pour
plein de choses
eh ben je j'ai l'impression qu'on perd
un peu de temps et qu'on n'arrive pas
encore à rebondir assez vite là dessus
c'est le moment fort de la réunion ça à
froid et c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
les gens y viennent pendant un moment on
est tous frères ah oui c'est vrai mais
faudrait que ça dure pour les que ça
dure